what's the deal with airplane peanuts
big difference between the Golden Globes
and the NFL on the Golden Globes we have
fewer camera shots of Taylor Swift we
watched the Joe Koy Golden Globes intro
and it was fine even the Taylor Swift
joke was good and Mild he just delivered
it like a bashful Asian gisha girl like
I said I didn't write all these that
one's not right k a killer he does
Arenas he's got his own fans he'll be
fine but it's a this is a different gig
and this is straight up a hell gig hell
gig Oppenheimer is based on a 721 page
piter prize winning book about the
Manhattan Project and Barbie is on a
plasic doll with big boobies gu should
have come out and and talked about the
fact that they chose him 10 days ago
because no one else in Hollywood wanted
the gig that's the premise I would have
gone with and said no wonder no one
wants this gig can't make fun of anybody
anymore Joe Koy has been getting dragged
online this week after a rough
appearance hosting the Golden Globes a
gig that was was accepted by koi on just
10 days notice the opening monologue
that's now making headlines included
jokes about Taylor Swift and the Barbie
movie that had plenty of women upset
online as well as comments throwing his
own writers under the bus that had
fellow comedians scratching their heads
and last weekend we had the chance to
ask a few Comics what they think of the
Golden Globes drama during our time at
the sunshine Comedy Fest when it comes
to joeoy hosting the Golden Globes I
think comedians should stay away from
that because when it comes to something
that mainstreams said at that time of
the day how funny can you really be
comedy is about pushing the boundaries
so how much is mainstream TV going to
allow you to push the boundaries
comedians stay the away from the Golden
Globes allow these yes
and allow these yes and
improv allow these improv actors who
have never did 20 minutes of standup to
host and go to Globe standup comedy is a
dying art so don't allow standup
comedians to host the Golden Globes
allow these yes and improv actors to
host the Golden Gloves bro so that we
don't get a bad rap because the Golden
Gloves are not going to allow you to be
what you truly are and that's edgy pushy
the [__] that people love you for other
comedy drama new comedy news Joe Koy is
getting dragged online getting a lot of
heat for his set at the Golden Globes do
you think comedians should still be
hosting these events if they're just
going to get trashed in the end it
sounds like they're kind of setting them
up to fail in a way yeah but listen dude
uh my mom used to tell me when I was
little uh any publicity is good
publicity you know what I'm saying like
controversy creates clicks so I
understand why they're doing it right
like I feel like comedy's the last
actual art the last actual Freedom right
but you go in a realm of which it's not
Comics they're going to judge you but
dude like at the same time you know
about it and you ask me about it because
he said that [__] right right same [__]
awareness definitely awareness would you
have you ever got in trouble with the
Taylor Swift fan group that's kind of
who's going after him right now oh those
aren my people those no I like single
mothers yeah all right another question
related to some new comedy drama Joe Koy
is in the news he's getting heed for his
Golden Globes uh didn't like it yeah
they didn't like it he made fun of
Taylor Swift they didn't like that
they're saying why did he Host this he
it all up should comedians even host
these award shows anymore what do you
think about that I think it should all
be AI hosts I should it should be AI
host just leading off reading off like
uh intensive lists of allegations
associated with everyone in every
project that's even mentioned on the
broadcast if at the very least it should
be scrolling across the bottom just the
pending criminal cases against these
[__] Psychopaths and then you've got
just a guy with the fakest teeth ever
like calling Taylor Swift like too
popular it's like damn dude wow what a
[__] show they need the AI Ricky your
face some more podcast drama or comedy
drama I should say Joe Koy is getting
some heat online right now for his
appearance at the Golden Globes what do
you think about that comedians keep
hosting these award shows do you have
any jokes about Taylor Swift fans that
gotten you in trouble what's the deal
with this joke always situation I love
that you asked me about the Golden
Globes dude do I look like a human who
watches the golden I don't know what a
they do I don't know I don't know what
it's for you know what the Golden Gloves
mean less to me than the what AVN Awards
like the porn Awards I'd rather I'd
rather see who wins the porn Awards and
be like Oh Riley re again then be like
what is a gloen glow bro yeah I have no
idea what about award shows in general
comedians hosting them they kind of put
them in bad spots but sometimes there's
Great Moments Like Ricky race would you
support comedian hosting award shows or
if they said we should do a ban would
you agree with that as well the problem
is I think comedians have to host award
shows it's the only way to keep it like
entertaining this is what we'll do right
we take a one-year Hiatus comedians
don't host any of the shows and you let
[__] George Clooney host them and I
bet you the next year you go I'm so
sorry for everything please give us any
Taylor Swift joke you have we'll do
anything that's a very good point it's a
power move man comedians host the best
Joe Koy is getting a lot of heed for his
set at the Golden Globes what do you
think about him under all the scrutiny
right now should comedians keep even
doing award shows What's your your take
on all that I was talking to people at
the Sellar about how difficult is it's a
no- win situation the only way you win
is like you know it's rare that they
walk out where they think it was like
universally loved and you know I think
Joy's a great Joy's a joy Joe Koy is a
great comic and I think like he did a
great
job PL and simple I like it I mean if
it's in the budget for sure and never go
after the swifties that's one group of
people I would not want to piss off the
Swift and the vegans we also had an
amazing opportunity to speak with Mark
Norman and cam Patterson about this
story but I'm a dumbass and didn't
record any
[Music]
audio so please enjoy this clip while I
continue to contemplate the best way to
off myself I don't want to go right for
the Golden Gloves and maybe bomb it's a
bad crowd and you see like I didn't
watch I you know I saw Clips but I was
watching like you know DeNiro kind of
gave him like like I want you could tell
he's like a vet he's like I want this
guy to do well I think Theo respect
Comics you know but then there's some
people there like the Taylor Swift
moment and now the Swifty is going after
him I'm like you know what really bugs
me about the Taylor Swift audience is
like she's doing well yeah she doesn't
need you every second of the day to be
like how dare you I know you think that
really hurt of course it was like a it
was not a good joke but it wasn't even
like an offensive joke but also Joe is
funny and he's a 30-year comic he's been
around where the hell was the Riff I
would have gone like boy Oppenheimer
blah blah blah okay well that bomb tooo
you know some get give me some tap
dancing it's tough when you're live on
TV like you know what I mean like it's
one thing to riff in a in a comedy club
or a theater or something but like I get
it live on TV like it it could get worse
that's true he RI that line about his
writers how great was another stting in
the crown wasn't she
M her portrayal of the queen was so good
Prince Harry called her for and asked
her for
money like I said I didn't write all
these that one's not mine h oh God that
was not that's brutal that was a bad
that was a bad riff bad move bad move
you don't ever throw the writers cuz
first off it's like you're watching this
set and you're like this guy had Riders
o you know what I mean and now you're
throwing them under the bus yeah I think
I a lot of people don't know we have
like like we don't have writers as
standups but like in award show of
course it's like a short notice thing
you have help you know what that felt
like it felt like you ever got like a
fist fight in high school and one of
your friends runs off and you're like
that [__] we all got our ass
kicked and he ran to the arcade or
whatever that's what that felt like like
it was him it was him it wasn't me and
you're like you red me out in 2 seconds
yeah but yeah that was tough but he'll
be fine Coy's a killer he's he's done
the Forum he does all these crazy gigs
so he'll he'll be just fine and you're
right he'll have 20 minutes on this and
that's going to be almost worth it cuz
that's going to be so fun to watch that
re exactly that's the thing it's like
people are going to want to hear this
there's already been some comedians who
have begun to publicly draw lines in the
sand about hosting these gigs including
Kevin Hart Who said said he's out on all
award shows in an interview published
last Friday saying quote whatever little
hope you had I want to destroy it right
now those gigs aren't good gigs for
Comics it's no shot to the Oscars no
shot to the Globes or anything else
those just aren't comedy friendly
environments anymore it seems like we
might be nearing the end of the days
that comedians are the first choice to
host Hollywood award shows which is
probably in everyone's best interest
after seeing a comedian who made $30
million last year on the road get
treated like a Nobody by swifties for
one bad set but let me know in the
comments what you think of Joe Ko's
Golden Globes monologue and what this
means moving forward guess spots from
last week The Joe Rogan Experience had
on Jim Brewer and Jim Norton two bears
one cave was Tom and Ryan sickler killed
Tony this week was with Lou Katz Tony
hinchcliff was on not today pal ymh
spoke with jawing Summers we might be
drunk had Shad Daniels on the show as
did are you garbage steo was a guest on
Whiskey Ginger Leslie Jones was on tiger
belly and bad friends had on David Spade
wow I had no idea how could you not we
couldn't stop talking about this you I
forgot you scheduled this you scheduled
this I drove here from ohigh at 7 in the
morning oh no ohigh that's insane insane
say hi to David hey thanks for coming
such a big fan I'm so sorry I'll make it
up to you I know you're actually angry
David dare you yeah are you Furious he
should be no 32
movies oh [__] 15 I've never seen you
like this listen to I listen 77
commercials yeah I understand
listen let him finish one
book um and a holding deal uh Bobby what
did I text you this morning I go wake up
today is your Super
Bowl this past weekend with Theo Von
talked with Shane Gillis Theo was on
Matt and Shane secret podcast the blocks
podcast had on fluffy Being Ian with
Jordan welcome Shane Torres Andy Haynes
and Mike Rine visited stav's World Josh
Adam Myers was on you know what dude Roy
wood junr went on Soder first date
featured Howie Mandel Daniel's personal
Chef was on the Tosh show and the Legion
of skanks YouTube channel was
permanently deleted last weekend which
we'll talk about in more detail later
this week as far as new standup comedy
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon Dusty slay workingman
and Dave Chappelle the dreamer are both
out on Netflix right now also out on
YouTube is Taylor Williamson live at The
Comedy Store Ian bag vers the government
Andy Haynes the suggested comedy special
and dude Z released an AI generated
George Carlin special that has amassed
over 400,000 views and caused George
Marin's daughter to speak out against AI
generated specials which is a situation
we'll be covering in an upcoming video
on our second Channel clip world if you
want to check that out also a few
specials in the works right now that
will be coming out soon Eric Andre live
near Broadway is coming to Adult Swim on
January 18th then Lori Kil Martin's new
special releases January 30th followed
by Taylor Tomlinson have it all which
premieres globally on Netflix February
13th 2024 from Joe Koy and Cat Williams
drama to Legion of skank censorship 2024
has started off red hot with comedy news
and we'll be sure to have you covered
every step of the way right here on joke
world as you saw in this video we just
got done attending the sunshine Comedy
Festival last weekend where we spent the
entire time interviewing comics and
collecting exclusive footage that I
can't wait to share with you guys over
the next few weeks also if you voted in
the first annual joke World Awards we'll
have the result video coming out
sometime in the next few days thank you
for watching and please subscribe if
y'all ain't [__] with jokeer who are
you [__] with let's [__]
go
joke
world that's
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out